so this one here uh i just saw this on
barcelo that joey diaz is
moving new jersey and stopping the
podcast i guess september is last month
and no like details if he's gonna do it
again
i don't know exactly why um you know
yeah wait what'd you say i was reading
that so joey diaz is planning to move
yeah to new jersey see i thought last
time i thought maybe he's considering
austin like all you know obviously i
heard he was offered a good deal by
rogan
you know like like he gave him offer
like he almost couldn't refuse but then
he decided to go to jersey anyways
i will tell you you know i i've known
joe for
joey forever man we he babysit kids
he i i he lived with me before i had
kids
like this dude i've known forever i knew
him when he was 220 pounds
and wore a three-piece suit on stage
like i've i've known him forever
i know i look man he i'm sure he's gonna
say why he's leaving so
it's not up to me to tell his story
because he says something about being
yeah
uh it's pretty long i'm not sure exactly
where he could there's no way
it's where he cut out the part where he
talks about it let's see no
it's where he grew up man a lot of his
friends are
back there that's where he's from dude
that's where he's from
and he's not going away he's just gonna
change
a little bit but i think he's ready he's
been ready to get out of la for
years as a lot of us have he's ready
and he's right he's 50
and how long has he been here you know
what i'm saying like he's been for like
it's been
i've been here for since 2012 i moved
here so eight years
and even me you know the only thing that
keeps me here is finding the kid i'm not
hollywood i don't do movies i don't do
tv gigs like i could do stand up for
many where the [ __ ] i want and tour you
know like i need to
uh me and theo can get together you know
once or twice a month and knock out king
of the sting
below the belts my show showtime's gonna
put up shop wherever i go
the only thing that keeps me here is
firing the kid you need you know i
haven't been here as long as joey i'm
sick of ellie if you tell me i can't
hang out with all my friends
that's what it is i'm out too that's
what it is and so and
and he moved down he came down probably
four months after i did so that's
19. he probably got here in 97.
um and um
he's just ready he's not gonna podcast
anymore he's gonna podcast in jersey oh
he is yeah he's gonna podcast
he says he's gonna stop yeah that was
the thing that i was worried about yeah
no no no he he's gonna i just don't
think he's gonna call the church or
what's happening
he's gonna call it the pada bing i think
i think he because
lee's not going with him i think he's
just lee lee's not going to leave
well listen there was a chance he was
really yeah man because that's the crew
james he's going with ro hops yeah he's
going through if i went to texas chin
and cat would come with me
yeah you always have this conversation
right so you that's part of the show
and and leigh's going to go where the
work is but i think joe is still going
to do
pods um i know that he started talking
to somebody
i'm not going to say who about doing a
pod with them in jersey
uh yeah so so like he's got plans man
this dude is a hustler
well he also sells a [ __ ] ton yeah dude
and a hustle hustle hustle that's not
going to stop
and his voice isn't going to stop it's
just going to come also joey's
you know to rogan's defense where you
know he's going to bring him along you
know
you could say joey's one of the main
reasons why brogan's show got so big
because you know joey was one of the
main characters you know there's
characters on rogan
joey diaz the best character he's the
funniest guy in the world dude i go back
to
chelsea chelsea's show couldn't have
gone without her but without
the group on the round table like jokoya
you all you guys it
it it is a it's obviously enhances
your shoes on there you joking a ton of
people man did you think joe could get
this big
hard to do how about you how about i'm
calling the other day because i wanted
to uh co-host the show
and he goes dude give me a second uh
i'll call you in a few days and take a
picture because i have to sign
something like ten thousand of these
little things his own bowel head yeah
nice
yeah i was like [ __ ] he he he's i did
did you expect him to be this big no
but i'll say something else about the
fortune was on the show
i'll tell you something else that he is
the whole list there hustler dude
yeah you know he used to sit outside
that laugh factory
every night handing out flyers giving
away free [ __ ]
i mean man for a while this show was
just
non-stop joe coy's a beast i opened for
him
so much because i thought i was good
with merch dude no he's a man
oh dude you know he has a dj on the
stage before does dj just playing just
his tunes he's doing his thing then the
dj's there while the openers come on
and the dj the whole system moves away
and then joe hits the stage and his
merch is like
second to none he had uh levi's custom
levi jack yeah with you know from the
ghetto to the getty which
i rock all the time but he used to which
was smart
before he went on stage he'd have all of
his merch
up on not not actual but like pictures
of his merch
on stage yeah he's a genius and a great
my favorite
he's a great combination for me and
again man i just
i respect hustle i respect it so much
such a nice guy uh but hustles and is
talented dude his stand-up is
yeah dude when i get off stage at the
lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song